that was that young I don't know you
just been following me around lately
like they just be bringing with me but I
don't know kind of creeping me out
I want to do what a business is boy
blaze that Ridge around 4sc and right
now we are on the rocks with a key let's
go yeah I started collecting like two
years ago first when I got all right
here was from icebox thinking like
28,000 I paid for this in my head yeah
it most definitely a special place
because for one is my first piece that I
did custom and they got my brother on
the bed he died I witness to represent
him like me and was very close to path
dim is my label doesn't money and that's
the family in 2009 that ain't exactly
when I started rapping but that's like
when we came up with the diamond brand
then I got like the marijuana me
I actually don't smoke right now cuz I'm
on probation but I most definitely beef
in a week it's flooded you know I went
ice box because like at first I just
seen all the rappers posting them i feel
like they overcharged me because I know
about Jordan but now I'm on
I got this one this is my cocky piece
cocky is the Carolina Gamecocks just one
of my favorite pieces right here I like
the detail I like like the message
that's behind it like they stadium is on
the same Road is my neighborhood
see he got the change like me I put the
48 number for that that's my
neighborhood I put forth a on and then
on the back I put blood on me in there
oh this was like 30,000 just for the
trunk and then the chain was like twelve
thousand apiece if I think it's like a
ten point uh something like that not too
big
I gotta upgrade my pointer soon but it's
my favorite piece man cocky we we go
crazy we had like three girls last night
I had to get one this is my last piece I
got fries but I still look like my shot
at the wheel but I've been locked in
with Drew and I mean I don't went all
over the world with Justin jewelers like
I don't want the press thing I don't
want the ice box
I want the wide-field I don't want in it
and Houston like we don't want all over
the place with this not this one this is
my beach boy like I only bring this out
like when I got a show or when I'm
coming to GQ and I gotta show these
folks what's going on I don't want to
keep talking [ __ ] but I was doing to
start this whole baguette in the chain
all the person I've seen with baguettes
is like I seen quite over here like the
UH the rings of [ __ ] but I was the first
to be I was hipped on this first right
so this is my favorites like the big boy
here are the girls like one team we put
the double scenes behind everything
I'll be happy to take a break with this
like last night on the Sprinter like I
thought guy friend is done doing all the
media [ __ ] like I just took it off I'll
be needing brace like this suckers heavy
this white girl right here I like white
and rose that's my favorite thing
I almost everything I got like white and
rose it's like a statement man a trophy
and I like to see how creative I can get
with the stuff to most of the things I
get was like after accomplishment like
maybe I drop an album with something
like that something bigger B didn't
happen I just go by Jordan reward myself
I travel with most of but I keep someone
in the safe I really like leaving it
over I like to have it on
right is my ap is my favorite watch I
got my eyes on another watch I want at
Cartier watch but for now this is my
favorite watch api paid fifty five
thousand for this from pristine jewel
honeycomb is like like poverty sitting
but it's like it got like the honeycomb
looks like a [ __ ] look how to watch
this right I love this watch I wish when
every day every day like I fall asleep
with his own like that's how much I love
it
and it got like the details in the back
I call it like this it got a brain of
his own oh if you could see it well
right it's a whole nother world back
then it's just your eye look at my phone
Sun to tell time I probably got it
sitting right ya ain't gotta say right
this right here is still presidential
Rolex split the file also just come from
niche it's heavy
it's way heavier than this but like if I
want to put on gold like you are black
or something like that you want to
switch it up you can just put the gold
on it look good yeah I used to wear two
watches at once I put both on different
sides like yeah but not just put on the
honeycomb just took it out remember your
first watch my first watch probably like
a g-shot watch that was my first watch I
thought I was [ __ ] into it
everybody hit that put the diamonds on
it I used to do it
I thought needs to put the diamonds on
gee shucks but now they got like
Christian movies and [ __ ] like they're
like yeah it's kind of similar but it's
just big dollar status nothing I like
those but my eyes is really on the
Cartier watch I want that the skeleton
[Music]
next up is my rings there's a trapping
[ __ ] right here trapper [ __ ] ring is my
favorite one like this is a statement
ring right here he got number 48 on the
2009 then we got enemy on the side this
is $20,000 right here it's like a
wedding I got these from pristine this
was like sent 500 apiece was a long time
ago I got these and I was like thrilled
I have brought for these at a time when
I lost three they probably my house or
something like
I just can't find me hopefully that come
up I almost lost my bracelet the other
day with my cousin she found it like we
was at the fair to my kids to the fair
it was in town if they're allowed by the
time I realized it was gone she was like
holla I'd be right back I had to get for
like $400 just because she she went and
found it for me like I would have been
hurt I was trying to suck it up as the
lostalready but I was like damn now I'm
tired of losing bracelets just like a
bigger one pain is the same price like
75 for this I got Haddie
I'll put on all my drill and I'm
performing it most definite ideas
dangerous but it's like I know that's
what they couldn't see like people want
to see that in person so it's like you
gotta get where they want to see these
of these are twelve thousand apiece I
overpaid for these two pristine when we
leave but we gotta put some screening on
it I like to match everything I got I
like most of my pieces is like honeycomb
with the baguettes on Easter played it
mister 803 was my area code was one of
my favorite pieces what inspired this
like I was his wife I was like I want a
chain with like three crosses I guess
like a cross on each the same kind of
like chain like that but I wanted to say
8:03 it's my first time doing like this
this just came on though I ain't seen
nobody do [ __ ] it sound like a choker
but I got to forget my thing on it too
like it's all go get out it work yeah
when I put the big one all black is that
piece I just put that on first and then
I'll it I put the small goes on just let
it stay like the smaller ones get lost
with the big [ __ ] just my own SMG piece
this was a gift from Allah and Carter
ain't getting a whole lot of money so
they just gave me this [ __ ] I got a
brother right
females watches and [ __ ] I don't but I
didn't get my own board changed like
yeah we do that outside
I just brought these I got this from a
Julien and I just needed some earrings I
had a video shoot so I need some quick
[ __ ] and he was treating them like 5000
I am a spiritual long as I can remember
when I was on the realize what it was I
always tell my mom or like time is money
so my brother and I used to always have
like Giuliana stuff of course yeah ain't
nobody [ __ ] with this it's just a
smaller one abyssal it's the damn you
want you got another partner of ours
that we lost our picture to me not just
the newest one that's dear me it's a
baguette it's just like the black second
one but it's like [ __ ] hard this is like
20 2002 everybody's doing this [ __ ] I
like this [ __ ] cards we gotta think of
something else no ICLEI tell ya I gotta
go CLE outside and we got to come up
with some hard [ __ ] besides me and
that's a harmless
it's lightnings I stuff I like gonna
hereby I sent a little baby home I like
the pump color forgery - like antler
yeah I like this [ __ ] so listen though I
always say like companies I like see
everybody sign plus I got out of this
before I was like I just did it because
I seen the rap was doing it I was like
this what they call crazy
I am I to spend a million in truth but I
feel like I'd really like helped me in
the music too because like when people
didn't know who I was like it was like
holder [ __ ] buying all this you're
like but there see like the Jew is
posting me and stuff like that so I just
did this [ __ ] for fun I just started
buying it just fine when you come to my
church probably all enough spent like
800 times at least a hundred times it's
not immediate
that'll be hard that might be the next
one this right here this is my foot a
piece got to put on for the hood you
know I got Dimmie right there
sitting on top with corner chain on the
ten points I think I play like 15,000
for the trunk like 10,000 for this just
like the last chain up and off when I do
from biggest to smallest this be like my
last when I put on because it just said
I was like the way a seat like I live
know where I'm from I actually thought
about getting a girl like I might do
that for my birthday I ain't come up
with like a crazy idea but almost
everyone forgets in it if I do it like I
got to do that to make it match
everything cuz I got off well yeah I
really get no grill yet because all the
females like my smile this is just like
a little taste this is where I travel
with but I'm coming back where I learn
so we're doing apart - y'all gonna have
to get a bigger table cuz we're gonna
flood this [ __ ] trap like that got right
now and go get that chump change
[Music]
you